and crashing hey everybody it's me miss
cracker and I am here at BuzzFeed to
tell you about my first time we got a
box here with all these little questions
I'm gonna tell you about the first time
I did every one of these things let's go
into it the first thing you think when
you hear lip-synch for your life
I think of RuPaul's beautiful but
threatening [ __ ] Monay exchange the
time has come like the most important
part of that voice is to release twice
as much air as you need
miss cracker the time has come for you
to lip-synch for your life I can't say
it my first drag name another one to
kiss they go I'm Kevin my second drag
game though was Briana crackers just
like brie on a cracker just my favorite
snack so I was like I mean I'm not gonna
do drag for that long probably just this
week so it doesn't have to be like a
classy name in here we yeah first Queen
I would love to see compete on all-stars
five I would have to say shake cool eh
because the match is fashion in a way
that I resent she's out there wearing
outfits that are so incredible all the
time I'm like damn it can you take a day
off so I could read oh my god this is
personal how dare you ask this my first
a I am account name you never ask a
woman her first am account name desk for
Scully because Gillian Anderson's
character and the x-files didn't have a
desk and feminism
first time meeting Roberta Elaine the
drag queen otherwise known as Bob the
drag queen
I actually met Bob the drag queen on the
screech he was struggling a bookcase
home in the snow and I was like I'm a
good Samaritan I'm gonna help after we
hauled that bookcase to the snow we got
to his apartment and I looked around it
was full of wigs I was like oh my god
what have I gotten myself into and the
rest is history my first celebrity crush
was I'm basic we know this is Jude Law
I used to download pictures of
when you had to download them stripe by
stripe on dial-up that's commitment
kids these days don't know about that
kind of celebrity love if you can't love
me at my dial-up you don't deserve me at
my high speed internet my first job for
all your West Coasters was working at
the QF see the quality food center as a
bag boy and I was so unqualified for the
job that I didn't get along the first
interview and my dad had to come in and
speak to the manager like you have no
idea what a treasure you're missing and
so I became head bag boy on register 1
and I have to tell you it's a skill I
still use to this day like not a joke
it's just a fact first thing you do when
you wake up I'm not gonna lie
I look at Instagram first selfie on
Instagram first of all this is fashion
my first selfie on Instagram this is
actually a really good story because it
says a lot about me this is me lying in
a bathtub halfway through my face
because I had been throwing up
throughout the entire powdering process
I was gonna go do the show anyway and
god I have never missed a gig had me
back then still have not and I would do
a number go throw up do a number throw
up and come back finish the show I am
proud of this selfie because it says a
lot about myself beep yeah this is duct
tape cuz I used to stack my wigs so I
would duct tape a wig to my head and
then duct tape another wig over that
first time performing in drag today
actually is my friend now my first time
performing in drag was at a little bar
in New York that's now closed
it's called excess and it was Bob the
drag queen and frosty flakes show but at
that time bob was kitten with a whip and
then when I actually did my performance
I got so into it would I bent over the
back of my dress completely unzipped and
both of my sock titties fell out so
illusion broken illusion broken which
incidentally is the name of my new
autobiography illusion broken my first
kiss was in the back of a Baptist Church
while they were playing too
panic because romance first time
realizing you were famous the first time
I realized I was famous you know I think
it was just the other day actually
because I was googling images for my
show while I was googling drag race all
these pictures of me kept coming out and
like why are they oh my god I was on
that show and that it finally sunk in
after like over a year so yeah I just
realized here's our last question first
my first pet was a tuxedo cat named
Misha she was bigger than me
I'm still a cat lady and guess what more
and more so over the years something to
look forward to
that's all the questions for today in
first times I'm very excited to be here
in New York for just a minute for my
one-woman show American woman which is
about to premiere at the Lory Beechmont
Theater and then hit every single
continent in the world except Antarctica
because I'm leaving that for shangela
[Music]